Can you talk about caster oil packs?
I have all the materials, but have it hesitant to do it.
How do they work?
How do they help someone with cancer?
Especially if cancer is in the liver.
So I recommend caster oil packs over the liver,
mainly that's all I recommend is using
caster oil packs over the liver.
Caster oil packs just help the flow,
they'll help decrease the viscosity of the bile.
They're my healthy, the bile flow through the colon bile duct.
And into the gall bladder, it out into the tomato.
So that's how caster oil packs work.
Even if you have cancer in the liver,
even if you don't have cancer in the liver,
they help move things through the liver.
So yes, go ahead and use them.
We'd have instructions in your manual.